CORVETTE NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LETTER. PLAYED A PROP.
WE ARE HOLDING MANY HEARING
HERE IN THE CAPITAL. OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. TODAY WE HAVE SENATOR
GLAZER PRESS ANY REMOTELY. AT
THIS TIME A LAST SENATOR GLAZER
NOT ONLY TIDY HIMSELF BUT HIS
STAFF MEMBER IF ANY IN HIS
OFFICE. WE WILL GIVE HIM A FEW
SECONDS. WE WILL COME BACK TO
SENATOR GLAZER IN A FEW SECONDS.
AND I WILL REMIND REMIND THE
SENATOR AS A REMINDER TO PEACE
MUTE HIS PHONE AND COMPUTER.
THIS WILL GREATLY EIGHT AND
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASK THAT WHEN YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED PLEASE
USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP
UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE. ONCE
I WILL GIVE GLAZER IF SECONDS
TO BE PRESENT. WELCOME CENTER
GLAZER PLEASE ALSO IDENTIFY KEY
STAFF MEMBERS IN YOUR OFFICE
THANK YOU. THAT SENATOR GLAZERS
HERE AND I HAVE DOES STAFF AT
MY OFFICE. THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK. YOU WILL SEE THE POP UP
WINDOW WHAT THAT WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON
MUTE PLEASE SELECT A NEW BEFORE
YOU. BEGIN SPEAKING ARE IT
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECKONED. PLEASE BE SEATED.
GREEN NAME AND THEN YOU'RE
READY TO THE- TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO IT TO
FIVE TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUAL
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTY. FOR AN
ACCESS CODE IT POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THIS. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TO DATE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. FIVE SIX FOUR
SIX NINE FOUR SIX. ONCE AGAIN
THE ACCESS CODE IS. FIVE SIX
FOUR SIX NINE FOUR SIX. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE IN
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE- QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT TIME YOU WILL BE.
EIGHT YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. A NON
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM TO CARRY AS IT
IS CUSTOMARY AT ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE CONNECT. WELL
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN A
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ALL MY- TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENCE TO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
FOUR BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
INCLUDING. TO PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT. CONSULTANT AT THIS
TIME I WILL ASK THE CONSULTANT
TO PLEASE CALL ROLE THANK YOU.
RUBIO PRESENT WILL BE A PROBLEM
HELLO. THERE JONES FALLS IN
MARCH ELEVENTH. THERE WAS A LOT
OF PRESENT. HERE MOBILE PORTALS.
ALL PRESIDENT. GALGIANI PRESENT
ONE THOUSAND PLEASE HERE.
SENATOR GLITTER GLUE HELP HERE
I HEARD WAS AND HEAR THE-
PLEASE APPROVAL HUESO HERE HOME.
MITCHELL MODEL PRESIDENT FOR
ALL POLL PORTANTINO. LOCAL LAW
BLACKWELL MANAGER WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU THE
CONSULTANT NOTE THE CRIME HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED LET'S HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHORED TODAY
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY
WELCOME YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE
MEMBERS NICE TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY. VERY NICE VERY NICE
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE IN A WHILE
FOR FIRE AREAS IS VERY
PROBLEMATIC AS WE ALL KNOW.
LAST YEAR WHEN THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED HOMEOWNERS CONSUMER
PROTECTION BILL THAT I CARRIED.
HE PUT ON HIS SIGNING MESSAGES
THAT WE MUST DO MORE IN THIS
AREA. THIS BILL I BELIEVE IS AN
INNOVATIVE BIPARTISAN APPROACH
TO ENCOURAGE INSURERS TO WRITE
MORE POLICIES FOR HOMEOWNERS
INSURANCE. IN OUR STATES HI
FIRE RISK REGION'S. CURRENTLY
THE ONLY OPTION FOR MANY
HOMEOWNERS IS THE FAIR PLAN.
THE FAIR PLAN IS IMPORTANT AND
HELPFUL SO HOMEOWNERS ALWAYS
HAVE AT LEAST ONE OPTION. IS
FOR MANY IT'S THE CHOICE OF
LAST RESORT. IT'S THE FAIR PLAN
IS EXPENSIVE BECAUSE IT'S
EXCLUSIVELY A HIGH RISK POOL.
AUTHORIZES INSURANCE COMPANIES
TO FILE A SPECIFIC PLAN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE THE
DRESSES THAT INSURERS PRACTICAL
NEEDS FOR RATES AND OTHER
DETAILS. CONTRATAR GIVENS BEING
MADE BY OPPONENTS THE BILL DOES
NOT IN ANY WAY CHANGE OR LIMIT
THE AUTHORITY OF THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER UNDER PROPOSITION
ONE OH THREE. THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT INSURANCE
REGULATION INITIATIVE ADOPTED
BY THE VOTERS. DOES NOT LIMIT
IN ANYWAY HIS ABILITY TO
APPROVE OR REJECT A MARKET
ACTION PLAN FILING. THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY RECOGNIZES THE
COMMISSION'S PRIOR APPROVAL
AUTHORITY. AND THE COMMITTEE
HAS SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS WHICH
ARE HARDLY EMBRACE TO MAKE THAT
POINT ABSOLUTELY CLEAR.
ADDITIONALLY RECENT AMENDMENTS
AT A SUNSET CLAUSE AND PROVIDE
DETAILS. TO THE LA- STUDY
PROPOSED IN THE BILL. THESE
AMENDMENTS SHOW THE COMMITMENT
THAT I HAVE TO ENSURE THE
PROGRAM'S EFFECTIVENESS WE WANT
THIS BILL AND THE MECHANISMS IN
THE BILL TO WORK. TO CREATE
MORE OPTIONS AND WELL FAR AREAS
FOR HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND A COMPANY
FOR RIGHT THAT POLICY. IF ANY
PLAN BY AN INSURER IS APPROVED
BY THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
THE INSURER WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
A LEGAL MANDATE TO INCREASE THE
VOLUME OF POLICIES IT OFFERS.
TO HOMEOWNERS IN CALIFORNIA'S
HIGH FIRE RISK REGIONS AND ALL
THAT WILL BE UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST I VOTE ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I AM INSTITUTING A
LIMIT OF FOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
FOR FOUR MINUTES. FOR EACH SIDE.
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
AND SUPPORT PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. CAN YOU MAY BEGIN.
OKAY THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF CERTAIN TAYLOR WITH
THE PERSONAL INSURANCE
FEDERATION. WE SHOULD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
AND THE ADDITIONAL PRECAUTIONS
THAT EVERYONE IS TO THE CAN
HELP KEEP US ALL SAFE LET HERE
WE WERE ASKED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
GET COMFORTABLE BEING
UNCOMFORTABLE. AND TO WORK ON
SOLUTIONS TO THE CHALLENGES
HOMEOWNERS AND HIGH FIRE THREAT
AREAS ARE EXPERIENCING. WITH
REGARD TO FINDING A POLICY FROM
THE ADMITTED MARKET ENSURE.
WITH THAT IN MIND WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS MEASURE ALONG WITH IS
COMPANION BILL SB TWO NINETY
TWO BY CHAIR RUBIO. PROVIDE A
COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM. REQUIRES
INSURERS WITH AN IMPROVED HI
MAP TO WRITE IN HIGH RISK AREAS
AND WILL ALSO HELP REDUCE RISK
OF LOSS TO THE VISUAL HOME
HARDENING A COMMUNITY WIDE
MEDICATION REQUIREMENTS. AS YOU
ARE AWARE CALIFORNIANS AND HIGH
FIRE THREAT AREAS OFTEN TURN TO
THE CALIFORNIA. FAIR PLAN IS
OUR ONLY OPTION. IN A OF WHEN
RESORT THE FAIR PLAN GENERALLY
MORE EXPENSIVE THAN REGULAR
INSURANCE AND PROVIDES LESS
ROBUST COVERAGE. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE BETTER COVERAGE AT
LOWER PRICES THAN THE THEN FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE NO OTHER
OPTION THAN THE FAIR PLAN.
INCLUDES AN ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT BY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO DEMONSTRATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE AYE
MAP PROGRAM. NOW A OF FALSELY
CLAIMED THAT THIS BILL WILL
TAKE AWAY POWER FROM THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER. AND
RAISE PRICES THAT'S- IS NOT
TRUE. AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN
CLEARLY REQUIRES THAT ALL I MET
RATE FILINGS ARE SUBJECT TO
APPROVAL BY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER. IN FACT THE
SECTION TWO OF THE BILL
UNEQUIVOCALLY STATE A RATE
PROPOSED AS PART OF AN IMF
FILING SO NOT BE EXCESSIVE
INADEQUATE OR UNFAIRLY
DISCRIMINATORY AND SHALL BE
ACTUALLY SOUND. AND A RATE
REQUEST AND I'M NOT FILING
SHALL BE SUBJECT TO THE PRIOR
APPROVAL OF THE COMMISSIONER.
NOW AS MR DALY NOTED THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS FURTHER
CLARIFY. THAT IT MUST FOLLOW
ALL OF PROP ONE OF THREE
STATUTES. AND THAT THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER CAN SAY
NO TO ANY I MET FILING FOR ANY
REASON. FURTHER. THE CONSUMER
ADVOCATES CAN INTERVENE JUST AS
A DO TODAY. THE BILL TO NOT
ALTER THE EXISTING PROBLEMS
TRANSPARENCY RULES OR IN ANY
WAY LIMIT THE ABILITY FOR INTO
THE NURSE TO OBJECT TO ANY PART
OF AN IMF FINALLY. IN REALITY
ALL THIS BILL DOES IS ALLOW A
MINUTE MARKET INSURERS TO MAKE
A PROPOSAL TO THE DEPARTMENT.
WHICH SPECIFIES HOW THEY WILL
SERVE THESE HIGH RISK AREAS AT
RATES THAT ARE LOWER THAN THE
FAIR PLAN. TO THE EXTENT
INSURANCE RATES ARE INCREASING.
THAT IS A CONSEQUENCE OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S EXISTING WAIT
METHODOLOGY. WHICH REQUIRES A
TWENTY YEAR LOOK BACK PERIOD
THAT INCLUDES TWENTY SIX
BILLION OF LOSSES INCURRED BY
HOME INSURERS. AS A RESULT OF
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WILDFIRES. IN FACT
MOODY'S INVESTORS SERVICE
RECENTLY REPORTED THAT
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
LOSS RATIOS FOR THE HIGHEST IN
THE NATION. ANY SERIOUS
SOLUTION MUST RECOGNIZE THAT
REALITY AND THE NEW NORMAL OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. WE THINK THE
BILL'S PROVIDE AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH THE BALANCES ENSURE
RISK IN RATES IN COMBINATION
WITH A STRONG EFFORT TO
MITIGATE WILDFIRE RISK OF LOSS.
AND IT IS AN APPROACH ENSURES
CAN SUPPORT WITHOUT FEAR OF
INSOLVENCY. IT DOWN TO ONE
MINUTE PLEASE OKAY IN SHORT WE
JUST WANT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A
PROPOSAL TO THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THAT WILL ALLOW
INSURERS TO COMPETE IN HIGH
FIRE THREAT. AS PRICES OUT OF
LOWER THAN THE FAIR PLAN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ST JOHN OR WHAT ON WE
HAVE THE INDEPENDENT INSURANCE
AGENTS BROKERS A CALIFORNIA
THERE'S NO QUESTION THERE ARE
MEMBERS ARE HAVING A DIFFICULT
TIME FINDING INSURANCE
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE- FOR THEIR
CLIENTS IN THE WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE- HAVE INSURANCE
PROFESSIONALS THE MEMBERS OF
OUR GROUP THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE
BUSINESS FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
OR MORE THEY HAVE NEVER HAD A
POLICY OF THE FAIR PLAN YET TO.
NUMBER HE'S THE FAIR PLAN IS A
UNDER. SITUATION BUT
UNDERSTANDABLE GIVEN THE JUST A
FEW YEARS AGO A MAJOR FIRE IN
CALIFORNIA MAYBE TO THE BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF DAMAGE. NOW
ARE SUBJECT TO FIRES THAT
REGULARLY AND KERR TEN BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF DAMAGE SO IT
IS A VERY TOUGH SITUATION
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE TENSE WHAT
IS. TENSE. TWENTY ONE THIRTY
SEVEN IS ON INNOVATIVE AND
THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORTED- AS IT
WAS INDICATED THAT ALLOWS
INSURERS TO PUT TOGETHER A
PROGRAM AND REQUIRES INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER APPROVAL IT DOES
SO WITHIN THE TWO MAIN
PARAMETERS A PROP ONE OH THREE.
APPROVAL AND LOWERING INSURANCE
RATES CONSUMERS THESE RATES
WILL BE LOWER THAN THE FAIR
PLAN FOR THOSE REASONS- WE ARE
DRIVE OUT ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
LOOK AT THE OPPOSITION FIFTEEN
SECONDS EXTRA. ANYONE ANY OTHER
WITNESS WITH WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEE NO
WITNESSES ARE NOW WE WILL MOVE
ON TO TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
AND- TEST BUT TESTIMONY
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN. WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MATTER
CHAIRPERSON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE
CALL. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE DIDN'T THEIR OWN NOW. ONE
MOMENT HERE. LINE THIRTY SEVEN
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD
LIKE SHERRY MAKE YOU. THAT IN
THE PACIFIC ASSOCIATION A
MOMENT YOUR MOM PLEASE. PEOPLE
WE MOVE FORWARD I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST EVERY TEST ON THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE LINE- DUE
TO TIME LIMITATIONS JUST PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ONLY THANK YOU. OKAY LINE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SHERRY MCCUE
REPRESENTING THE PACIFIC
ASSOCIATION OF DOMESTIC
INSURANCE COMPANY AND SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
MARK SECOND WITH THE AMERICAN
PROPERTY CASUALLY INSURANCE
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. MY NUMBER TWENTY SIX
IN ON IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER TWENTY SIX. THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING I'M MONTHLY- REPRESENT
THE FAIR BANNED ME TO PUT THE
BILL. IF NUMBER THIRTY TWO
YOU'RE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I NEVER THIRTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER THIRTY
THREE GET ON AN OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE JENNIFER
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR YEAH LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ANNA
BACK UP WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS YEAH
ACTUALLY HAVE A NEUTRAL
POSITION ON THE BILL I'M MORE
HOPEFUL THAT THEY STILL.
PACKAGE WILL CREATE. OUR. IT'S
NOT. THANK YOU. AS A REMINDER
JUST STAY YOUR NAME YOU'RE
GONNA STATION AND YOUR POSITION
I WOULD HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF IF
YOU CONTINUE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN WELL
NUMBER THIRTY UNITED OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CATHY
FREEMAN REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IN THE COURT THANK YOU.
NUMBER THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING STACEY HEATING RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT AS YOU
KNOW THEM. MADAM CHAIRWOMAN
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
MODERATOR PLEASE JUST CHECK ONE
MORE TIME TO SEE THIS ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN. YES
MA'AM LATER ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THE ROLE. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE SIX SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
COMMENTATOR MADAM CHAIRWOMAN WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU.
SAYS IN HERE FROM THE
OPPOSITION. LET'S START WITH
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
CHAMBER PLEASE- IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND YOU MAY BEGAN AS A
REMINDER. YOU HAVE OF FOUR
MINUTES BETWEEN BOTH IF YOU AND
I WILL EXTEND THE SAME COURTESY
OF FIFTEEN SECONDS THANK YOU.
THANK CAN WE HAVE THE SAME IF
YOU HAVE TO WITNESSES CAN WE
HAVE YOU ON THE SAME SIDE TO
EXPEDITE THE PROCESS THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE
BEHALF OF COMMISSIONER LADA.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
COMMISSIONER LOT OF BECAUSE OF
THE HEARING WAS PUSHED OUT BUT
HE WANTED ACTUALLY TESTIFY ON
THIS MEASURE INSTEAD OF. HIS
REPRESENTATIVE. I WANTED
ACTUALLY. INQUIRE TO BE STILL
BE ABLE TO. AT THIS AT THIS
TIME HE NEEDS TO EITHER CALL IN
OR YOU WOULD HAVE TO PRESENT
HIS POSITION. THANK YOU. CAN I
WANTED TO START THE CLOCK SOON
SO I UNDERSTAND THIS REFERENCE
TO TESTIFY OF COURSE GMAT AGAIN
OF COURSE THE DENTURE BUT I
WILL CAN WE HOLD OFF FOR A
SECOND WE HAVE SECURED THE
COMMISSIONER ON THE LINE
THAT'S- OKAY. MISSION WELCOME A
YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHARTER RUBIO AND VICE CHAIR
JONES THIS IS YOUR CALIFORNIA
XIN COMMERCIAL RICARDO LARA I
WANT TO PERSONALLY TESTIFYING
STRONG OPPOSITION AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN YOU KNOW I THE LEAD
REGULATOR OF THE STATE'S
LARGEST. CAPTION AGENCY MY JOB
IS TO LOOK OUT FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS INCLUDING YOUR
CONSTITUENTS CAN EITHER RED AND
BLUE DISTRICT THIS. THIS IS THE
LAND THAT I USED TO RUN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. OVER THE LAST YEAR
I'VE HEARD FROM THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS AT TOWN HALL HELD UP
NOT ONLY UP AND DOWN THE STATE
BUT LITERALLY AND VIRTUALLY BY
SIDE WITH MANY OF YOU- ABOUT
THE INCREASING INSURANCE
PREMIUMS AND NON RENEWAL. TIME
AND TIME AGAIN RESIDENTS SHARE
ANY OUT OF REACH FOR IT IS THE
THERE IS NO MANDATE PUNISH.
GUARANTEE YOU'LL AND RENEWED IT
COVERED WHEN ARE ALREADY. MORE
IN A HIGH PREMIUM. AND WHEN
THEY SPEND. TO MITIGATE. HARD
AGAINST FIRES WHAT THE DUE
RESPECT NO ONE NEGATIVELY AND
SO YOUR COMPLETE I HAVE YOU
KNOW HOW PERSPECTIVE OPPOSE
THAT AND FIGHT ANY ATTEMPT THAT
ARE GOING ON AND HARM TO THE
FELLOW SUFFERING FROM WHILE
PLAN INCREASES. BECAUSE OF
THEIR CURRENT. AB SIX. THE LAB
AND CONCERT RATHER IT BENEFIT
INSURANCE COME. BUT A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS OF. AT THE OF
RESIDENT IN MAJOR AND USE MY
WEIGHT EVEN HIGHER PUSH DOCTOR.
PART OF WHAT FAMILY FAST TRACK.
OF INSURANCE COMPANIES. BOND
INSURANCE A. THE INCLUSION OF
ON REGULATE WE IN. THAT ARE
REGULATED BY THE OF INSURANCE
AND DO NOT ADHERE TO WORK PUT
AND POP ONE OF THREE IF YOU. OF
THE IN. OF THE GREAT COMPANY
CATASTROPHE. CLOAK FROM- PUBLIC
GOVERNMENT AND FIRST RESPONDERS
ONE NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE VERY
AND METHODOLOGIES USED.
CALCULATE HIGHER RATE ON TOOK A-
AND THE- ACOSTA GROUPS FULLY
PARTICIPATE RATE YOU. THEN IN.
TODAY UNDER PROP ONE OF UNDER
MY DISAGREE WITH THE FULL
PREMISE THE CURRENT RATE MAKING
PROCESS OTHER IS NOT WORKING
TODAY ISSUE ARE UP AT THE
DEPARTMENT STORE IN A PRESS NOT.
IF THE INSURANCE COMPANY CAN
DEMONSTRATE A FIVE THE FILE
RATE UNDER PROP ONE OF THREE IS
NOT SAID NOT AN ADEQUATE AND
NOT ON DISKS. THAT ARE GREAT.
APPROVED THE. IT MAY TAKE A
SPOT VERY SAID. TO ENSURE THE
SOLVENCY OF THE MORE.
ESPECIALLY AFTER OUR FIVE I
BELIEVE THERE'S EXISTING PROFIT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT ARE THAT
TODAY FOR ITS COMPANY. TO
REQUEST ADEQUATE RATE IT IS UP
TO THE INSURANCE HARPER TO. THE
COVER LOSSES. ON IN NINETEEN.
DIGITAL MINOR DOWNTIME AND. FOR
JEAN THE PROPER THE CARD DRAFT
THAT RULE OUT BY THE TO ALLOW
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION SPECIFIC
FIGHTING RIGHT LOWER THAN EVER
PERCENT. NOTHING THIS THE IT'S
JUST A FACT OF GREAT FINDING
STUFF TO IT HI ARE REGULATED
INSURANCE. AND SO NOT A MEMBER
CHAIR MEMBERS EVERY THE YOU
KNOW AGAIN OWNER UNDER THE BILL
PUTS ALL OWNER IF ON THE
CONCERT. TO CONTINUE PAY HIGHER
RATES WHAT MAN IT THAT. NUMBER
VERY CAMINO ALL IN FOR THE
REASONS I OPPOSED TWO ONE
PICKED SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ENSURE COMMISSIONER THANK
FOR PART. YOUR DOWN. TWENTY OF
YOU HAVE ANYBODY ELSE. SEEING
NONE NONE NOW WE WILL LOOK AT
BROUGH TWENTY FORTY FOR ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN. IT SEEN NINE WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE ONCE
AGAIN WE WILL REMIND EVERYONE
CALLING AND THAT. THEY MAY
STATE THEIR NAME THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR AND
THEIR POSITION ONLY THANK YOU.
MODERATOR. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE ALL. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU MODERATOR. WAIT I'VE BEEN
INFORMED THAT THERE IS ANOTHER
WITNESS AND I WOULD LIKE TO GET
ON THE TWENTY SECONDS HARVEY I
BELIEVE IS ON THE LINE. TWENTY
SECONDS. MODERATOR DO WE SEE
HARVEY ON THE ON THE LINE I.
NOT IF THEY ARE ON THE PHONE
FIVE STAR NAY THEIR OWN. OKAY
ONE MOMENT THEY'RE KILLING
THEIR TUNE UP NOW ONE MOMENT.
MY NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SORRY ABOUT THAT MADAM CHAIR
IT'S HARVEY ROSENFIELD WITH
CONSUMER WATCHDOG I'M SPEAKING
TO YOU TODAY IS THE AUTHOR OF
PROPOSITION ONE OF THREE IN THE
PERSON WHO LED THE CAMPAIGN FOR
ITS PASSAGE I'M GOING TO GIVE
FIVE. QUICK REASONS WHY- THE
EIGHTY TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN
IS A VERY BAD IDEA FIRST OF ALL
CONTRARY TO ALL THE ARGUMENTS
MADE BY THE COUNTY THREE
SECONDS GOING TO RAISE. SORRY.
MADAM CHAIR. I'M SORRY MR. BY
TIME HAVE MINUTES AND FIFTEEN
SECONDS COLLECTIVELY WITH BY
WITHOUT COMMISSIONER LADA YOU
CAN CALL IN AS A AT THE WITNESS
AND SUPPORTER IN OPPOSITION.
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO. ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
ON TELECONFERENCE. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THE ROLE. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB TWO TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
THEIR OWN NOW ONE MOMENT. MY
NUMBER THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS ROBERT CORRAL
DECORATIVE DIRECTOR OF THE. AND
MASSIVE RATE HIKE WE SHOULD BE
HAVE ONLY PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION PLEASE. OKAY ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
TWO ZERO. THE MANAGER WOMAN
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q. CAN
YOU PLEASE CHECK ONE MORE TIME
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS NO ONE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN. YES OUT
OF THE CHAIR WOMAN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THAN THEIR OWN NOW. IN LINE
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS HARVEY ROSENFIELD I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A MOMENT
OR TWO TO SPEAK. I WILL GIVE
YOU ANOTHER FIFTEEN SECONDS AT
A COURTESY THIS IS A VERY- AN
ICY NALO CHALLENGING BILL AND I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
IS TREATED EQUALLY AND DONNA
BUT I WILL GIVE YOU FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF SECONDS. OKAY THIS
BILL WILL RAISE RATES ON
HOMEOWNERS AND RENTERS BY ABOUT
4250% IT PROPOSITION ONE OH
THREE DOES NOT APPLY- UNDER
THIS BILL PEOPLE WOULD NOT BE
PROTECTED IT'S FULL OF
LOOPHOLES IT'S ON AN ON
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT TO
PROPOSITION ONE OH THREE I
REJECT COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
VOTE. NO KILL ARE PARTY AB.
WRITER ANY OTHER ARE WISHING TO
SPEAK CAN YOU LET ME KNOW HOW
MANY DO WE HAVE STILL WE NEED
TO SPEAK. AT A TIME ENTER WOMAN
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR EVERYONE THE CALL
TEN AND THOSE TESTIFYING HERE
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO MEMBERS
ARE WISHING TO SPEAK TO HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. WE WILL START
WITH MISTER DOT. THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS FIRST
MISTER DODD- CAN YOU GET CLOSER
TO THE MICROPHONE I BELIEVE HE
CAN'T HEAR YOU AS CLEARLY THANK
YOU. YEAH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY CAN WE
HOLD ON FOR ONE SECOND I'M
STILL HAVING A CHALLENGE WITH
YOUR MICROPHONE CAN WE DOUBLE
TRACK. WE GET WARMER TIME. HOW
YOU LIKE IN THIS HI LIKE ME SO
FAR. THANK MUCH BETTER THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GREAT.
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO FAKE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY IN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS
FOR WORKING INCREDIBLY HARD ON
THIS BILL AND TRIED TO ADDRESS
A LOT OF CONCERNS- THAT- WERE
INITIALLY IDENTIFIED. I HAD
pAND HAD SOME VERY INSIGHTFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH THE
SUPPORT IN THE OPPOSITION. MY
BIGGEST CONCERN WITH INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER BE EMPOWERED TO
REJECT ANY HI MAP FILING THE
DOES IT BENEFIT CONSUMERS. I
DON'T WANT TO SEE STEEP RATE
HIKES OR LITTLE GROWTH AND
COMPETITION- IT AVAILABLE BILL
THE OF PAUL IN THESE- FIRE
PRONE AREAS. I SHARE MY CONCERN
WITH THE CHAIR I SHARED MY
CONCERNS WITH THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS RESPONDED
DIRECTLY TO THAT POINT. IT OUR
SHIRTS SURE HAS THE FLOOR TO
ENSURE ENOUGH BE APPROVED. IF
IT DOESN'T BENEFIT CONSUMERS. I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY THAT A
RATE PROPOSED AS PART OF AN IMF
FILING IS SUBJECT TO
PROPOSITION ONE OH THREE
REQUIREMENTS. PETE THAT BUT
THEN A RATE PROPOSED AS PART OF
AN ITEM OUT FINALLY IT IS
SUBJECT TO PROP ONE OH THREE
REQUIREMENTS. THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS LAST WEEK WERE ALSO
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
ADDING A SUNSET PROVISION AS
WELL AS REQUIRING A REPORT ON
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF A MAP
PROGRAM. I BELIEVE IT IS GOING
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION WILL
VOTE ARE YOU TODAY. I
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE STILL
CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION
AND I URGE THE AUTHOR TO WORK
WITH THE COMMISSIONER AND THE
OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE THE BILL. I'VE YET TO
SEE DATA ON CURRENT MARKET
PENETRATION- IN THE LIKELY MY
AYE MAIL COUNTIES UNDERSTATING
THE STATUS QUO IS IMPORTANT TO
JUDGING WHETHER THE EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT. WE ARE MADE IN THE
BILL'S BENEFICIAL. OR YOU LOSE.
TWICE TO SEE THAT BEFORE THIS
BILL REACHES THE FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER JONES. YOU MA'AM
CHAIR IS THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER STILL ON THE LINE.
FOR IS HE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CHECK. CARP HIS
ASSISTANT THE TERROR- IS
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS THAT
WOULD BE FINE TO. GNOME
DIRECTOR LARA HAD DISCONNECTED.
IS REPRESENTATIVE STILL HERE.
WE'LL GIVE HIM A FEW MORE
SECONDS I JUST HAD A CLARIFYING
QUESTION ONE OF HIS COMMENTS-
MISTER MARTINEZ WOULD TO LIKE
TO TAKE THAT QUESTION SURE
ABSOLUTELY HE'S FROM THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
HE WILL BE TAKING THE QUESTION
FORM SORRY JONES. MISTER
MARTINEZ- TAKING A QUESTION FOR
YOU SENSATIONS OF THERE'S
NOTHING I THINK HIS ARCHES
THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF
CONVERSATION- THIS MORNING
ALREADY ON THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS AUTHORITY BEING-
I GUESS AND- INFLOW. OR
CONTROLLED BY THIS PARTICULAR
BILL IN ONE OF THE COMMENTS WAS
AT THE- RATE REVIEW AND PROP ON
ALL THREE. ARE GOING TO BE-
INTERRUPTED- BY THIS BILL. ARE
YOU ABLE TO CITE A SPECIFIC
PARAMETERS THE BILL THAT THE
CAUSES THAT CONCERN. SO LONG
MAYOR SHOULD GET. THE TAXES
WHILE. I WHILE YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE REASON FOR THE QUESTION
IS YOU KNOW THE PROPONENTS OF
THE BILL AND THE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL BOTH SPENT. CREDIT AT
A TIME AND- EFFORT ON. ONE SIDE
EXPLAINING THAT IT DOESN'T ONE
SIDE EXPLAINING THAT IT DOES.
AND SOME JUST ONE IF THE
OPPOSITION'S ABLE TO KIND OF
POINT TO EXACTLY WHERE IN THE
BILL THAT. THAT THE PROBLEM IS
.
TO MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND I ALSO HAVE HERE WITH
ME BRENT HANLEY A SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO THE COMMISSIONER-
BECAUSE IT'S ALSO TO SOME
DEGREE TO POLICY DEBATE AS WELL
AS A LEGAL DISCUSSION AND SINCE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LAWYER
HERE. IN SERVICE. JUST THAT THE
BOOK IN THE AND THIS IS ALL AN
A AND COMPANY WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN AS
OUTLINED IN THE BILL'S ANALYSIS
THAT. MISSION ON THE DEPARTMENT
STILL DO BELIEVE THAT THE
AMENDMENTS DO NOT ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THE COMMISSION. AND
THE DEPARTMENT HAVE ON THE BILL.
AMENDMENTS CONTINUE TO KEEP HE
BELIEVES IN THE DEPARTMENT
BELIEVES OVERRIDES HAS
AUTHORITY. TO DENY AND I AM OUT
FINALLY AND ONCE IT HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT. AND
SO IN OTHER WORDS THAT ONCE THE
RATE ONE OF THESE RATE FILINGS
IS APPROVED THEN. THE KNOWLEDGE
YOU LIKE THE HORSE IS OUT OF
THE BARN- IT'S OUT THERE AND
THAT THE INSURANCE COMPANY FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE. CAN JUST ROLL
BACK TO THE PREVIOUS I'M NOT
RATES AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE
COMMISSION DEPARTMENT COULD BE.
PERILOUS INTERFERE WITH THE
PREVIOUS RATE EVEN IF IT'S NOT%
DEEMED EXCESSIVE. WITH THE
INCLUSION INCORPORATION OTHER
INSURANCE RATES. OF WHICH ARE
NOT REGULATED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE IT'S AN INCIDENT
HARLEY GLOBAL MARKET. THAT ALSO
COMPLICATES THE ABILITY FOR US
TO EVEN WITH THE MOMENTS OF
HAPPINESS THE LATER IN A PROP
ONE OF THREE. WOULD PROHIBIT US%
TO BE ABLE TO REALLY LOOK AT A
LOT. THE COSTA RICAN. AND THEN
ALSO THAT THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
BILL DO NOT REQUIRE INSURANCE
COMPANIES TO PRICE OR CELERY
NEW INSURANCE TO HOMEOWNERS TO
MEDICATE THEIR HOMES AGAINST
WALL VIRUS TODAY CAPTURES WILL.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU- VENTURE IF
I IF I COULD ASK FOR THE-
AUTHOR QUESTION IF THE
EXCITEMENT ACTUALLY TWO
QUESTIONS MR DAILY- YOU KNOW AS
AUTHORS OF BILLS WHENEVER
THERE'S A CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERN BROUGHT UP AS OF THE
OPPOSITION IS RAISED- WE ALWAYS
AS THE AUTHORS- WE GET A LETTER
FROM LEDGE COUNCIL TELLING US
THAT OUR BILLS. OUT A OR A THE
POSSIBILITY OF VIOLATING EITHER
THE U. S. CONSTITUTION OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. ALSO
ANY. MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
CAN REQUEST A LETTER OF- ASKING
THE SAME QUESTION AND THEN AS
THE AUTHOR THE BILL. YOUR
PROVIDED A COPY OF THAT LETTER.
IN ANOTHER- MEMBER ASKED THAT
SAME QUESTION WHICH COUNTS ARE
YOU FAMILIAR. WITH ANY OPINION
FROM LEDGE COUNCIL THAT STATES
THAT YOUR BILL IS POTENTIALLY A
CONSTITUTIONAL. I HAVE NOT SEEN
SUCH A AN OPINION- CENTER
JONES- MY COMMITTEE STAFF OF
PERSON IS HERE IN THE CHAMBER
IF YOU'RE WILLING TO LET HIM
COMMENT TO THAT OF MADAM CHAIR
IS THAT ACCEPTABLE ABSOLUTELY
AS HE AND THE CHAMBER. YOU MAY
STEP TO THE MICROPHONE PLEASE.
AND I HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
TO AND THEN I'M DONE VENTURE.
CENTER JONES IT IF THE QUESTION
WHETHER LEADS COUNCIL PROVIDED-
LETTER TO THE AUTHOR AT THE
TIME NO THEY SUBMITTED THE
INITIAL DRAFT LANGUAGE- WHICH
IS SUBSTANTIALLY IDENTICAL TO
WHAT'S IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY
THE ANSWER IS NO THEY DID NOT.
INDICATE THAT THE BILL WOULD BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL OKAY IF
ENACTED GRAY AND THEN AND ONE
MORE QUESTION GIVING DIFFERENCE
TO THE COMMISSIONER AND HIS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY IN THE
REVIEW. OF ONE OR THREE DO YOU
HAVE AN OPINION ON- HOW THE
COURTS USUALLY- FIND THESE
CASES WHEN. WHEN THE COURTS ARE
DECIDING A CASE BETWEEN THE
COMMISSIONER AND THE
LEGISLATURE- HISTORICALLY AND I
KNOW THIS IS AN OPINION AND I
APPRECIATE THAT TO THE COURTS
GIVE DIFFERENCE TO THE
PROPOSITION RECORDS GIVE
DEFERENCE. TO THE LEGISLATURE.
THERE'S VERY LITTLE CASE LAW. I
WENT OF COMBAT YES DOUBLE THE
MOTION THERE'S VERY LITTLE CASE
LAW DIRECTLY ON FROM ONE OF
THREE AND THE CASE LAW THAT
THERE DOES EXIST ON SO CALLED
FOR THE PURPOSES WAS
ESSENTIALLY THE LEGISLATURE
UNDOING A PROVISION OR USURPING
A DIRECT. A DIRECT DELEGATION
OF SPECIFIC WITH A WITH A
SPECIFIC METHODOLOGY TO THE
COMMISSIONER- THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN CAN PROPOSE SOMETHING FOR
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER TO
CONSIDER THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
VIOLATE THIS REGULATION IS NOT
THE INITIATIVE DOCTOR BUT HIS
REGULATIONS- THAT HAS NEVER
NOW. BELIEVE THAT- ACTIVISTS
BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE
COMPETITION IN THE AREA OF THIS
BUT THERE'S NO COMPETITION
FURTHER IS THAT. PURPOSE WHICH
IS EXPRESSLY POLLUTED ONE OF
THE PURPOSES PROP ONE OF THREE
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M SURE I'M. I'M I'M- FIVE
DANCERS OF THE IN AND AGREE
THAT THE ALLEGE CAN HAS A PINE
THAT THIS IS AN CONSERVE LIKE
WERE. WERE ACTUALLY GOING DOWN
A GOOD ROAD HERE WITH THIS
BILL- AND IF THERE AT SOME
POINT IN TIME DOES GET KICKED
INTO THE COURTS I'M CONFIDENT
THAT. IF THERE IS SOME KIND OF
PILED IN THE COURTS AND SUCH
AND SO I'M I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND-
LOOK FOR TO MISTER DALY
CONTINUING HIS CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COMMISSIONER AND-
ALLEVIATING SOME OF HIS
CONCERNS. THANK YOU MISTER
JOHNS WE WILL NOW MOVE OVER TO
SENATOR WITH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR. AND CAN I
JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS AND I
WILL ALSO ASK MISTER MARTINEZ
TO- MAYBE COME TO THE MIKE TO
IT FOR A FEW QUESTIONS BUT
BEFORE I DO THAT I WANT TO ASK
THE AUTHOR A QUESTION REAL
RELATED TO HIS ROLE AS THE
INSURANCE- CHAIR IN THE
ASSEMBLY. FATHER WAS A BILL AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY SEVEN BY
LAUREN AND SALAS THAT YOU
DECIDED NOT TO HEAR THAT WAS A
BILL THAT WAS VERY SIMILAR TO
THIS IT ENDEAVOR DO THE DO THE
VERY SAME THING THAT THIS
ATTEMPT. TO LOOK. UP ALL TO AT
LEAST LOOK OUT FOR THE THOSE
INSURERS TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
COVERED WELL I MEAN I WHAT WE
WANT AND I THINK WITH THIS BILL
PROPOSED REPORTS TO DO IS TO A
COVER PEOPLE AND TEACHER
CALIFORNIANS ARE COVERED AND
I'VE FOR THAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
THAT MORE OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
YOU ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR
INSURANCE. WE'VE ALSO SEEN
THAT- THERE HAS BEEN CONCERT
WITH CONSIDERABLE OF. A
CONSIDERABLE CHANGES IN THAT IN
WHICH- IT'S BEEN HARDER
RECENTLY BECAUSE OF THE
WILDFIRES BE FOR PEOPLE TO GET
INSURED IT HAS AFFECTED MY
DISTRICT SO I'VE HEARD FROM A
LOT OF CONSTITUENTS THAT THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE NOT
BEING FAIR TO THEM SO WHEN I
WHEN I LOOK AT AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY SEVEN HOURS FOR
ENCOURAGED BY THAT BILL. WE
ACTUALLY GOT A PRESENTATION IN
OUR COMMITTEE ON THAT BILL AND
WE HAD BEEN WORKING THROUGH OUR
CHILDREN THROUGH THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE TOGETHER WITH A
SOMBER ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOT OUT TO
WORK ON A POLICY THAT WOULD
ADDRESS THAT WE HAD AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON THIS ISSUE.
WE STEP THIS VERY THOROUGH
THROUGH THIS. AND THE BILL WAS
FORMULATED WITH FEEDBACK FROM
THIS COMMITTEE AND IT WASN'T
HURTING YOUR COMMITTEE AND I
JUST WANTED TO ASK YOU WHY WAS
THAT BILL NOT HEARD. SENATOR
THE BILL'S I DO HAVE SOME
SIMILARITIES- MY BILL USES
INCENTIVES. TO TRY TO STIMULATE
THE MARKET IN THOSE HARD TO
ENSURE AREAS OF CALIFORNIA.
THERE MANY OF THOSE AREAS
AROUND THE STATE. MISS GONZALEZ
IS BILL- WAS MORE A WAS MORE OF
A COMMAND AND CONTROL A TYPE OF
BILL CAN I THOUGHT MY BILL WITH
THE CARROT AND STICK. IN IT.
THE INCENTIVES IN IT. INCLUDING
SUCH FEATURES AS A SHORTER TIME
PERIOD FOR REVIEW BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE SO THAT
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES CAN GET
AN ANSWER AND THEN OFFER
INSURANCE IN THOSE AREAS. SO MY
BILL HAS SOME FEATURES THAT I
THINK- WILL STIMULATE THE
MARKETING GIVE CONSUMERS
CHOICES- HER BILL DID NOT HAVE
THOSE FEATURES IN MY OPINION-
THERE WERE SOME- IN BACKGROUND
DETAILS WHICH I'D RATHER NOT GO
INTO IN TERMS OF THE. IN A
PRESS CONFERENCE APPROACH TO
CARRYING A BILL- WAS ONE
FEATURE THAT TO I THOUGHT WAS
UNFORTUNATE NOT MY BILL BUT THE
OTHER ONE OKAY SO YOUR YOUR
ANSWER LEADS ME TO BELIEVE THAT
YOU WANTED TO LIMITED
DISCUSSION ON THIS AND HAVE US
ONLY HEAR YOUR BILL SO THAT
THEIR BILL WOULDN'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE DISCUSSED ARE
VOTED ON BY THE LEGISLATURE.
WESSEL CAN WE ADDRESS THE
MERITS OF THE BILL AT THIS
TIME- I THINK THEY WERE GETTING
INTO- STRANGE TERRITORY THERE
WERE QUESTIONING OUT THE
PROCESS OF THE ASSEMBLY.
BROTHER WE SPEAK TO THE MERITS
OF THE BILL IF WE IF WE CANNOT
INSURE THAT MADAM CHAIR BUT THE
PROCESS. IS VERY IMPORTANT. TO
THE LEGISLATIVE MAKING PROCESS
AND I RATHER. THAT WE DO
DISCUSS POLICY HERE PUBLIC
POLICY IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
IN ASSURING THAT WERE ABLE TO
VOTE. ON WHAT'S BEST FOR OUR-CONSTITUENTS. AND I APPRECIATE
THE IMPORTANCE ENORMOUS OF
POWER THAT ARE THE CHAIRMAN HAS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO DECIDE WHAT
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S BEEN MORE
SINISTER HERE. IN THIS PROCESS
WHEN. ONE IDEA IS SQUASHED AND
NOT EVEN DISCUSSED PUBLICLY.
WHY CAN'T WE HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION IF THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT IF THIS BILL WE NEED
TO HEAR THIS YEAR MADAM CHAIR.
WE NEED TO HEAR THIS BILL LET'S
GET THE POLICY RIGHT. AND I
HAVEN'T BEEN GIVEN THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THAT
PUBLICLY. AND TO ENSURE THAT WE
GET THIS RIGHT NOW I'M I'M- I'M
A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED BUT BY
THAT I'M DISAPPOINTED BY THAT
CONDUCT. I'M DISAPPOINTED BY
THEIR PRACTICE. AND I'D RATHER
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION HERE IF
YOU'LL PERMIT ME MADAM CHAIR.
CHRISTINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO. I'M GOING TO MOVE ON FROM
THAT SUBJECT I THINK I'VE
ESTABLISHED THE INTENT. OF
THOSE ACTIONS I'D LIKE TO MOVE
ON TO. MISTER MARTINEZ NOW.
THERE WAS A SPEAKER OF THAT
MENTIONED AND I. I'M OFTEN. A
LITTLE SKEPTICAL WHEN PEOPLE
CERTAINLY NOT VERY SPECIFIC
NUMBERS BUT A NUMBER WAS THROWN
OUT THE SUGGESTED THAT THIS
BILL WOULD CONTRIBUTE TO THE
INCREASE OF INSURANCE POLICIES
BY 40% I DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE
TO INQUIRE AS TO HOW THAT
NUMBER WAS DERIVED BUT IT'S
VERY CONCERNING AND IF THIS
LEGISLATURE ACTIONS. I WANT
KNOW OF THAT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE THAT VERY CLEAR SOMEONE
ASKED MISTER MARTINEZ IF HE IS
AWARE. OF ANY DATA FOR OF. ANY
ANALYSIS THAT OF CAN PROVE OR
ARGUE THAT THIS BILL WOULD
RESULT IN AN INCREASE IN RATES
FOR CONSUMERS OF OUR STATE. YES
MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER. WE WOULD SAY FLAT
OUT THAT YES THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE RATES INSURANCE RATES
ON CONSUMERS AND- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE THAT
EVEN A PROPONENTS WOULD SAY
THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
INCENTIVES IF YOU WILL FOR
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO WRITE
UNDER THIS BILL THAT THERE'S-
ALWAYS WHAT I'VE HEARD THAT. A
AND- THERE'S BEEN NO
DISAGREEMENT THAT THIS BILL
WILL INCREASE WILL INCREASE
COSTS ON TO CONSUMERS AND
POLICY HOLDERS WHO HAVE
MOURNERS. WOULD YOU BUT IF I
COULD JUST INTRODUCE. WOULD YOU
AGREE THAT UP REVAMPING THIS
PROGRAM WERE INCREASING
COVERAGE OR ANY BILL THAT WE
WORK TO MAKE SURE MORE PEOPLE
ARE ARE ARE OF A OF A COVERED
HAS TO RESULT IN AN INCREASE
IT'S FOR CONSUMERS. MISTER
MARTINEZ YES OF COURSE- I WOULD
SAY THAT. BUT ANSWERED IN AGAIN
IN A FEW WAYS IS THAT FIRSTLY
WE ARE ALSO OPERATING WITH THIS
BILL MOVING FORWARD THAT THE
CURRENT PROCESS OF RATE REVIEW
AND APPROVAL AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE DOES NOT WORK. IT
AGAIN IN THE PROCESS OF MOVING
THIS MEASURE AND WE CAN WE
ABSOLUTELY. DISAGREE WITH THAT
THAT UNDER THE EXISTING LAW
TODAY UNDER PROP ONE OF THREE.
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE COMPANIES
ARE LINING UP. AT THE
DEPARTMENT WITH DOUBLE DIGIT
INCREASES TODAY UNDER EXISTING
LAW WHICH INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND THE RATE
REGULATION STAFF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OR DUTIFULLY LOOKING
THROUGH. AND POURING THROUGH
AND THOSE THOSE ARE GETTING OUT
THE DOOR THOSE ARE BEING
APPROVED AND WE BELIEVE IN A
VERY TIMELY WAY. ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS- FOR GOOD MAJORITY OF
THEM OR IN A FOUR MONTH
TIMELINE BECAUSE PROPONENT OF
THOSE IS OUR IS PASSED. THANK
YOU HERE OF THE NECESSITY ONE
OF THE INCENTIVES UNDER THIS
MEASURE- AND SO WE WOULD AGAIN
FIRST OF ALL SAY THAT. THE
CURRENT PROCESS AT THE
DEPARTMENT INSURANCE IS NOT
BROKEN WE ARE SEEING WHERE.
PREMIUMS ARE RATES ARE ALREADY
BEEN APPROVED BY THE
COMMISSIONER ENDED FOR EXAMPLE
JUST LAST YEAR AND- IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THE COMMISSIONER.
DELTA APPROVED. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE 92% OF
RATE FILINGS THAT WERE OF
HOMEOWNERS RE FILINGS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED AGAIN LAST YEAR AND
TWENTY NINETEEN AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING WHERE AGENDA AND THAT
WOULD TO THAT EITHER CHANCE TO
IS THAT PEOPLE ARE GETTING
INCREASES TODAY AND PREMIUMS.
AND SO UNDER THIS MEASURE NOW
WITH THE INCLUSION OF
UNREGULATED REINSURANCE COSTS
SECRET CONFIDENTIAL CATASTROPHE
MODELS CLOAK FROM PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY RESTRICTING
CONSUMER GROUPS FROM FULLY
PARTICIPATING IN THE RATE
REVIEW PROCESS AND THE FAST
TRACK. ALL OF THAT IT WE
BELIEVE IS GOING. TO EQUAL TO
EVEN HIGHER. PREMIUMS PUSHED ON
CONSUMERS AND HARD WORKING
FAMILIES. AND ONE FOR THE LAST
QUESTION- IT RELATES TO THE
AMENDMENTS AND IN THE
AMENDMENTS- THE AMENDMENT
SUGGEST THAT- THE COMMISSIONERS
THIRTIES COMPLETELY RESTORED BY
THE BILL THAT THE- THE
COMMISSIONER'S AUTHORITY IS
FULLY IN PLACE NUMBER ONE AND
I'D LIKE TO DO- COMMENT ON THAT
AND- ANOTHER THERE'S ANOTHER
AMENDMENT THAT SPECIFIES THAT
THE DECISION IS NOT SUBJECT TO
JUDICIAL REVIEW- AGAIN I DON'T
KNOW THE PROCESS I GUESS NONE
OF US HERE ON THIS FLOOR
PROBABLY EXPERTS IN THIS AREA
OF LAW SO WE HAVE TO REALLY
RELY. ON EXPERTS TO. THIS IS.
THE SPECIFIED THE DECISION IS
NOT SUBJECT TO JUDICIAL REVIEW
IS SOMEWHAT CONCERNING TO ME. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS OF
MAYBE YOU COULD EXPLAIN THAT
BUT IF I IF OVERALL YOU CAN
GIVE ME YOUR OPINION IN TERMS
OF THE AMENDMENTS. AND WHETHER-
THEY ARE. OF THE HAVE THEY BEEN
DRAFTED WITH YOUR SATISFACTION
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
ROLE OF THE COMMISSIONER IS
STILL. COMPLETELY PROTECTED AND
HE MAINTAINS HIS POWER TO MAKE
THE ULTIMATE DECISION IN TERMS
OF WHAT. OF THE SEAS ARE INTO
PLACE. MIDDLE MARK YES TWENTY
SERVER SO AGAIN I MY COLLEAGUE
HERE BECAUSE THIS IS LARGER
LEGAL BUT IMPORTANT QUESTION-
BRAIN HENLEY WHO SERVES AS THE
COMMISSIONER SPECIAL COUNSEL
WILL ANSWER YOUR QUESTION AT A
HIGH LEVEL. GOOD AFTERNOON
CENTER HUESO AND COLLEAGUES-
BRIAN HANLEY SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA. TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
YES THE SUGGESTION OF
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THAT THE- DECISION OF THE
COMMISSIONER NOT TO HOLD A
HEARING IS NOT SUBJECT TO
JUDICIAL REVIEW IS DIRECTLY
CONTRARY TO AT LEAST TWO
PROVISIONS OF PROPOSITION ONE
OF THREE. AND SO BY THE VERY
TERMS OF THAT PROPOSED
AMENDMENT WOULD NOT FURTHER THE
PURPOSES OF PROPOSITION ONE OF
THREE AND COULD YOU EXPLAIN
WHAT THAT THAT AMENDMENT MEANS
DOES THAT MEAN THAT- THE RATE
PAYERS COULD NOT. CONTEST THE
DECISION. THAT THAT IS THE
LANGUAGE THAT SUGGESTS THE
COMMISSIONER WITH WHEN HE
CHOOSES NOT TO ALLOW. AND A
PROPOSED ON A MAP RATE TO BE
APPROVED AT THAT DECISION IS
NOT RECOUP YOUR VIEW WILL BY A
COURT THAT IS CORRECT CENTER
HUESO. WHAT THAT WOULD MEAN IS
CONSUMERS COULD NOT CHALLENGE
THAT DECISION OSTENSIBLY THE
WAY THAT WORDING HIS PROPOSED.
THAT VIOLATES PROPOSITION ONE
OF THREE WHICH SAYS THAT QUOTE
ON QUOTE. PERSON HAS THE RIGHT
TO CHALLENGE ANY ACTION OF THE
COMMISSIONER. THAT'S INSURANCE
CODE SECTION. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
ONE ONE ZERO. THE DISH. PROPER
ONE PRE PROVIDES THAT A THIS TO
DENY A FLING. AND NOT TO HOLD
A HEARING IS A FINAL DECISION
THAT IS SUBJECT TO REVIEW BY
THE COURTS THAT PROVISION FROM
PROP ONE OF THREE. IS INSURANCE
CODE SECTION ONE EIGHT SIX ONE
POINT ZERO NINE SO SENATOR WHO
IS A TO YOUR QUESTION IT IS
INDEED TRUE THAT THE WAY THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENT IS STATED.
CONSUMERS FROM CHALLENGING THE
COMMISSIONER'S DECISION NOT TO
APPROVE AN AYE MAP. WHEN IN
FACT PROPOSITION ONE OH THREE
SAYS QUITE THE OPPOSITE THAT
THE PUBLIC HAS THE RIGHT TO
CHALLENGE EVEN THE
COMMISSIONER'S DECISIONS. NOT
TO APPROVE FILINGS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND REGARDING THE
POWER OF. THE COMMISSIONER HAS
THAT BEEN RESTORED BY THE
AMENDMENTS. SERVE AWAY SO IT IS
NOT BEEN RESTORED BY THE
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS WHILE
MAKING REFERENCE TO PROPOSITION
ONE OH THREE BECAUSE THEY MUST
BECAUSE PROPOSITION ONE OH
THREE SAYS THAT ALL INSURANCE
RATES ARE SUBJECT TO THE
COMMISSIONERS PRIOR APPROVAL SO
WHAT THAT PROVISION SAYS IS
WHAT ALREADY EXISTS THROUGH
PROPOSITION ONE OF. THE
CONCERNS IN THIS MATTER ARE
THAT IT CREATES A NEW EXCESSIVE
STANDARD IN THE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL. IT
ADDITIONALLY PROVIDES IF THE
COMMISSIONER CHOOSES NOT TO
APPROVE A SUBSEQUENT LINEUP
FILING THE INSURER HAS A SAFE
HARBOR AUTOMATIC RIGHT INTO THE
PRIOR BATES. WILD AND APPROVED
BY THE COMMISSIONER. AND THAT
THE DID THEY COME DOESN'T HAVE
A TO ENFORCE PROMISES THAT THE
INSURER MADE IN THE ORIGINAL
FILING. THESE ARE ALL WAYS IN
WHICH THIS IS CONTRARY TO
PROPOSITION ONE OH THREE WHICH
GAVE TO THE COMMISSIONER AND
NOT TO THE LEGISLATURE WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO THIS MEMBERSHIP.
GAVE TO THE COMMISSIONER THE
BEST AND EXCLUSIVE POWER TO
DECIDE HOW RATE MAKING IS TO BE
DETERMINED. AND NOT GO ON AND I
UNDERSTAND A LOT OF BILLS HAVE
BEEN OF REMOVED FROM
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE OF
BECAUSE OF IT AND WITH THAT
THAT'S A LEGISLATURE WERE ONLY
REALLY CONSIDERING THE MOST
IMPORTANT BILLS AND THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE FACING OUR
STATE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN HOW
WHAT ARE REPAIRS PAY. WHAT
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED THAT MORE
PEOPLE ARE COVERED THIS IS
SOMETHING THIS LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO WORK DILIGENTLY TO
SOLVE WE ALL NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER BOTH HOUSES TO REALLY
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. AND I AND I
WAS FEELING IN COURAGE THAT ARE
ARE CHAIR THROUGH. OF TO OUR
COMMISSIONER WORKING THE BILL
THAT WOULD JUST DO THAT. I'VE
ONLY A BIG GUN TO ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS AND I'VE ALREADY
EXPOSED TO REAL THINGS. THAT
JUST TO NOT MEET. MY
SATISFACTION BUT THIS BILL IS
REALLY- THIS BILL WAS REALLY
WRITTEN TO. REPRESENT THE
INSURED THE RATE PAYERS. THAT
WE'RE LIMITING JUDICIAL REVIEW.
IS A VERY SAD THING TO CONSIDER
TODAY I HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU
AGREE. THAT IT DOES NOT NEED TO
BE IN THIS BILL THAT WE DO NOT-
THAT WE TAKE AWAY THE CITIZENS
RIGHT TO REVIEW DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THEIR LIVES IN VERY
PROFOUND WAYS WHY WOULD WE DO
THAT AS A LEGISLATURE. AND THAT.
THIS PURPORTS TO CONTINUE TO
RESTORE THE UP. A THE POWER OF
THE OF COMMISSIONER I HOPE ALL
OF YOU CAN SEE THAT THAT'S NOT
THE CASE. AND FOR THAT REASON
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I'D LIKE
TO CONSIDER IT AT CONTINUE
ASKING QUESTIONS BUT TO MY- AS
FAR AS I'M CONCERNED THE- I'VE
I'VE A- PRETTY MUCH EXPLODES
ENOUGH PROBLEMS TO MAKE ME WANT
TO TAKE A STEP BACK FROM
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. TODAY ARE
WELL I WOULD HOPE THAT THE
AUTHOR. HI BUT WE ASKED HER TO
GO BACK WITH A MISSIONARY WORK
ON SOME. THAT'S GOING TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA IT IS THAT IMPAIR.
AND I'M ANSWER THAT WE'RE JUST
RUSHED THIS. WITHOUT RE LOOK.
IN IT A TOOTH COMB. MEMBER OF
SENATE BILL. AND UP. WORK ON
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. WELL MISTER
BURGESS YOU WISH TO SPEAK MADAM
CHAIR TO A CROSS QUESTION IF I
MAY POSE TO THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE REPRESENT ABSOLUTELY.
PETER WALK ME THROUGH. WHEN A
INSURANCE COMPANY PROPOSES
RATES- IN INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER REVIEWS THEM. ARE
THOSE RATES OF FOUR OR THE
BASED ON A SINGLE READ A SINGLE
HOUSEHOLD A SINGLE RISK
CATEGORY WHAT IS THE PROFILE BY
WHICH DETERMINATION MADE BY THE
COMMISSIONER. THAT WOULD
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY'RE
ACCEPTED REJECTED OR GO BACK TO
THE DEFAULT RATE PRIOR. SENATOR
BORDERS THIS IS BRIAN HANLEY
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION THE
ANSWER IS THAT THE CURRENT
PROCESS PROPOSITION ONE OF
THREE TO ESTABLISH SEPARATE
SHALL NOT BE EXCESSIVE
INADEQUATE. OR UNFAIRLY
DISCRIMINATORY AND SHALL NOT
REMAIN IN EFFECT THAT ARE
EXCESSIVE BEYOND THAT IT LEFT
TO THE COMMISSIONER IN THE
COMMISSIONER ALONE THE POWER TO
ADOPT RULES TO THIS TO
ESTABLISH WHAT THAT MEANS. THE
COMMISSION HAS IN FACT ADOPTED
RULES AND IS ADOPTED THE RATE
MEETING FORMULA THAT
ESTABLISHES CARL RATES ARE
DETERMINED AND TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS AND WE'RE JUST. THE
REYES OF THE INCH. IS WHAT IS
FILE WITH THE- IT GOES THROUGH
A RATE MAKING. TO DETERMINE
THAT THE RATE PROPOSED. IS NOT
HIGHER THAN THE MAXIMUM
PERMITTED EARNED PREMIUM UNDER
A SET FORMULA SO IN SHORT
SENATOR. THAT IS AN OVERALL
RATE FORMULA LOOKING AT THE
STATE ENTIRELY. WITH THAT SAID
IN THE REVIEW OF THESE RATE
FILINGS THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND HIS STAFF DO
INDEED LOOK. AT HOW IMPACTS
WILL BE ON VARIOUS PARTS OF
REGIONS OF THE STATE. THAT
TECHNICALLY DOESN'T HAVE TO DO
WITH THE ROLE RATE MAKING
FORMULA THE MAXIMUM PERMITTED
EARNED. WHICH FOR A CROSS RATE.
TO WHAT IT IS THE IN WHAT THE
COMMISSION DOES IN REVIEWING
THESE FILINGS IS DETERMINED.
THAT RATES FOR DIFFERENT
REGIONS OF THE STATE SO THAT
WHERE RATES ARE LOWER FOR SOME
PEOPLE SAY IN AN URBAN SETTING.
BUT SO FAR IN THE RIPPLE SET.
TO BE ON FAIRLY DISK. FOR UNDER.
SO THE COMMISSION DOES WERE
THOSE. BUT STRICTLY SPEAKING
THE EXCESS OF THIS. IN THE FOR.
HAS TO DO WITH THE OVERALL
STATE RATE. FINAL QUESTION- ARE
THERE INSTANCES DURING THAT
REVIEW AN EXAMINATION PROCESS
THAT AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
REJECTING A RATE THAT THE
PROVIDE INSURANCE PROVIDER AND
THE STAFF OF THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER REVIEW THESE ARE
AT TOGETHER IN SOME FORMAT IN
ESSENTIALLY COME OUT WITH THE
NEGOTIATED A RATE THAT IS
APPROVED BY BOTH SETS OF
PARTIES. BETTER IT IS TRUE THAT
IN SOME CASES THERE IS THERE IS
ALWAYS A DISCUSSION BETWEEN THE
COMMISSIONER. THE INSURER AND
SOMETIMES THE PUBLIC THAT IS
ALWAYS PART OF THE PROCESS
WINDOWS PARTIES WISH TO SPEAK
AND DISCUSS THE ISSUE IT IS NOT
ALWAYS THE CASE THAT THE
PARTIES REACH AGREEMENT AND
UNDER PROPOSITION ONE OF THREE
CURRENTLY. WHEN THAT OCCURRED
IF THE COMMISSIONER DETERMINES
THAT RATES RIGHT NOW ARE
EXCESSIVE. SURE DOES NOT GET TO
GO BACK TO THE PRIOR RATES-
MUST DEAL WITH THE EXCESSIVE
RATES THAT EXIST NOW. THIS
PROPOSED BILL HOWEVER THAT
WOULD NO LONGER APPLY WITH
REGARD TO THE V. TWO ONE SIX
SEVEN INDEED THE LANGUAGE IN AB
TWO ONE SIX SEVEN EXPRESSLY
DISAGREES WITH A SUBSEQUENT BY
MAP FILING THE INSURER
AUTOMATICALLY GOES BACK TO THE
PRIOR RATE. EVEN IF THE
COMMISSION FINDS THAT THAT
PRIOR RATE IS EXCESSIVE. THIS
BILL SAYS THE INSURER HAS A
RIGHT TO GO BACK TO THAT RATE.
THAT IS CONTRARY TO THE CURRENT
LAW AND PROPOSITION ONE OF
THREE. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
MEMBERS OF TO MUST MAHER LOCK.
THANK YOU IT SURE LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE STANDING FOR. BUT TO. IF
FINANCIAL. DOES NOT RECEIVE.
APPROVAL OF AN ADEQUATE RATE TO.
MAKE IT FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE TO.
PROVIDE A POLICY IN A WILL BE
AREA THEN THAT ENSURE HAS THE
RIGHT TO. NOT MAKE AN OFFER AT
ALL. AND WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL
WITH INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE NOT
ABLE TO FIND INSURANCE. AND IF
THEY CAN'T FIND INSURANCE THEN
WE HAVE FAIR. AND SO IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT. THIS IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS THAT VACUUM. AND I'M
JUST CURIOUS. IF IT WERE ONLY
APPROVING 92% OF RATE INCREASES
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING UP
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAS OCCURRED
THE LAST FEW YEARS. I I'M JUST
CONCERNED THAT. NOT APPROVING
THIS BILL IS GOING TO PROVIDE.
MORE DELAYS IN TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT INSURERS WANT TO STAY
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU- ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK UP MR ALL. AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO MR DOLL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- TALKING ABOUT
SPEAKING ABOUT DELAYS I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET AN IDEA. IF THIS
BILL HAPPENS TO PASS OFF OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND PASSED THE
FLOOR. AND IS SIGNED HOW LONG
WILL IT TAKE FOR THE EFFECTS OF
THIS BILL TO REACH THE
HOMEOWNERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN SOMEONE ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. WE'LL GO TO MR
DAILIES ON STAFF. GO AHEAD
TODAY REFER TO HIS STAFF MR
DAILY CAN ANSWER IF HE CHOOSES
TO BECAUSE OF THE URGENCY OF
THE SITUATION AND NOT OF FIRE
AREAS. I'M MORE MORE HOMEOWNERS
ARE CHOOSING THE FAIR PLAY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO OTHER
VIABLE OPTION. THIS WOULD GO
INTO EFFECT IMMEDIATELY UPON
THE GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE IT
REQUIRES A TWO THIRDS VOTE IN
EACH HOUSE. AND WE FEEL I FEEL
THAT- IT'S AN URGENT ENOUGH
MATTER. IT'S HARD TO PASS A
BILL LIKE THAT BUT IF WE WANT
TO GO INTO EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
SIR. WELL I UNDERSTAND THAT
THROUGH THE AIR I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT THERE'S A HUNDRED AND
TWO IT A REVIEW THERE'S
BOTTLING THAT NEEDS TO BE A
SET. YOU HAVE HOMEOWNERS THAT
ARE ININ THE MIDDLE OF THE
POLICY PERIOD AND I'M ASSUMING
THAT THAT POLICY WOULD ALLOW.
WOULD REMAIN UNTIL THEIR- BUT-
IS HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE FOR
THE IMPACTS OF THIS BILL WILL
TO REACH. HOMEOWNERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS AT ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS. IS IT
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
IS. IS A THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY DAYS BECAUSE WE HAVE A- A
NEW LEGISLATIVE SESSION IT
STOPS IN JANUARY. THIS IS A
VERY. ISSUE I'M JUST. TO
UNDERSTAND. THE WHY AND TO MAKE
SURE IF WE EXECUTE ON THE WHY
THAT BETWEEN NOW AND JANUARY OR
NOW IN MARCH IT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO REACH A HOMEOWNER CAN
SOMEONE ANSWER THAT. APOLOGIZE
SENATOR I MISUNDERSTOOD YOUR
QUESTION- I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
EXACT SCHEDULE- THAT THE
DEPARTMENT MAY FOLLOW TO
IMPLEMENT THE BILL OR THAT
INSURERS MAY. MAY FOLLOW THERE
IS A LOT OF DATA THAT ONLY TO
BE GATHERED AND SO FORTH MAY I
ASK THE COMMITTEE CONSULTANT
TO. BRIEFLY ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. WHICH IS HOW SOON
WILL WE SEE RESULTS. MADAM
CHAIR IS ADAMS OKAY ABSOLUTELY
MARGARET GETS WITH THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE- AS MR
DAILY JUST INDICATED IT'S
DIFFICULT TO GIVE A PRECISE
ANSWER- TO THAT SET QUESTION
SENATE ROTH BECAUSE IT'S
CONTINGENT ON HOW QUICKLY
INSURANCE COMPANIES MAKE OF
VIOLENCE AND HOW QUICKLY THE
DEPARTMENT IS ABLE TO ACT ON
THEM WITH THEIR- LITIGATION
WHICH HAS THREATENED I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT. THE GONZALEZ
BILL THAT WAS MENTIONED BY
SENATOR HUESO IS CONTINGENT ON
THINGS THAT WOULD TAKE TWO TO
THREE YEARS TO IMPLEMENT SO
STONE WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL HAS THE BEST PRODUCT
PROSPECTS OF EIGHTY THE
PROPOSALS THAT WERE MADE THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR GET
SOMETHING ON THE STREET TWO
WILL. AREA HOME OWNERS THE PAST.
THANK YOU- WE HAVE ONE MORE
MISTER DOT. I YEP FOLLOWING UP
ON OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO'S COMMENTS- I'VE GOT A
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT- YOU KNOW
THE DIALOGUE NOT THAT- CONTENT
OF THE DIALOGUE JUST WE'RE- YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE GOING AT. IT
IN THIS POLICY AND SO I DID
CHECK WITH MY STAFF I REALLY
WANTED TO MAKE IT VERY VERY
CLEAR THAT. WE WORKED HARD TO
TRY TO GET THIS. THIS JUDICIAL
REVIEW PORTION IN HERE BECAUSE
WE KEPT HEARING FROM THE
OPPOSITION. THAT THAT THAT WAS
A PROBLEM IT SO I- I JUST I
TALKED TO- MY STAFF HERE AND-
HE HE SAYS THE OF SENATOR. IT
SAYS A DENIAL OF TWENTY AND IT
ANY INCREASE IS NOT SUBJECT TO
JUDICIAL REVIEW THAT PUTS THE
COMMISSIONER AS THE LAST WAR.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THAT
BECAUSE LET ME TELL YOU I WAS
AGAINST THIS BILL FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING BECAUSE I SERVE. A
HUGE WILDFIRE IS. I'VE BEEN
VERY DISSATISFIED ME THE AXE OF
THE INSURANCE DEPARTMENT NOT
SURE INSOFAR BUT THE INSURERS-
THE INDUSTRY OF INSURERS ED- SO
THIS WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME
THAT WE MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S- THE
COMMISSIONER. WILL HAVE THE
FINAL SAY IT'S SO TO ME THE WAY
THAT THIS IS BEING PRESENTED
IT'S KIND OF. YELLOW ACTUALLY
TAKING THE OTHER SIDE WILL WHY
WOULD THE INSURER. WHY WOULD BE
IN THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
FOR EXAMPLE BE UPSET IF PEOPLE.
WE'RE STILL WAITING TO- US TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE- THAT THE-
INSURE INSURERS CAN INCREASE
THE RATES. INTO OF COURSE HE
WOULD BUT THE REALITY IS. THIS
PROJECT WAS PUT IN THERE TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS IS WHAT I'M
TRYING TO SAY I APPRECIATE.
SEEING NO MORE INTEREST I WOULD
JUST. GO AHEAD MISTER TINA. YES
CHAIR I. THE HIGH RISE TO
SPEAKER I WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE
COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
RIVERSIDE MENTION THAT THE BILL
WE GOT OUT OF COMMITTEE WOULD
TEND TO GO TO THE FOR- IT
ACTUALLY WILL LOOK CREATION
SNACKS- IF IT GOES OFF OF FOR
TODAY AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS- I APPRECIATE. THE
HARD WORK THAT THE CHAIR AND
THE AUTHOR OF DONE- TRYING TO
GET AN IMPORTANT ISSUE. RIGHT
TEN THROUGH THE PROCESS- I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE MOVE
FORWARD BUT I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ON. SUCH STRONG
OPPOSITION FROM THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING WE SHOULD. WE SHOULD
TAKE NOTE OF AND ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMISSIONER TO
TRY TO FIND COMMON GROUND ON
SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE. I
THINK THE RATE INCREASE ISSUE
IS IMPORTANT. PASSAGE WITH THAT
LATER A MEMBER THERE MAY BE.
WORKS WITH THE AMENDMENTS ALL
OF THOSE ISSUES WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT. THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMISSION. HE
WOULD BE LOOKING VERY STRONGLY-
AND DISCERNING ON AND FOLLOWING
UP ON THE WORK THAT YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE OF DONE. AND SO
I'M GOING TO. SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY- WITH THOSE STRONG
RESERVATIONS AND NO ONE SHOULD
READ INTO- THAT VOTE THAT THE-
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
PASS OR NOT PASS THIS BILL
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT THOSE
ISSUES- WITH A VERY DISCERNING
EYE AND ENCOURAGING. THE
COMMISSIONER AND THE AUTHOR TO
WORK TOGETHER TO FIND THE SWEET
SPOT BECAUSE I THINK EVERYBODY
WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INSURANCE MARKETS ARE STRONG.
PEOPLE HAVE A- SCUM GO AND SO.
THOSE WILL BE THE CONCERT THAT
WILL BE LOOKING AT AND- WITH
THAT TO. UNDERSTANDING I'LL
PROVIDE A COURTESY VOTE I TODAY
BUT JUST WANT TO ASSURE
EVERYBODY THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT ALL THOSE ISSUES AS
IT MOVES FORWARD IF IT MOVES
ALL. THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH BETTER PORTANTINO. I YOU
KNOW I KNOW THEY WERE RUNNING
OUT OF TIME AND WE HAVE TO- AND
GO TO TALK IF I BELIEVE SO. I
WILL JUST MAKE THESE LAST
COMMENTS. AND SO JUST REALLY
QUICK BECAUSE I WANT TO DRESS
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT THEY
CAME UP AND I REALLY WANT TO
JUST GIVE- SOMETIME FOCUSED ON
HARVEY ROSENFIELD BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT HE WAS ON THE CALL
AND THE COMMISSIONER TOOK ALL
HIS TIME AND- MY JOB IS TO BE
FAIR AND- HE- REALLY ARE MINE.
NEEDS TO NOT ONLY BE FAIR BUT-
THEY'RE ANTI ONE. FILLED THE
LAVELL TO STAY TO SPEAK WITH
HIM AND TALK TO HIM AND WE
CANNOT TALK ABOUT INSURANCE AND
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS WITHOUT
SPEAKING ABOUT HIM HE WAS THE-
PROPONENT OF WANT WANT MY PROP
ONE OH THREE. AND DIE HE SINGLE
HANDEDLY SAY SO MANY CONSUMERS
A LOT OF MONEY SO WE NEED TO
GIVE CREDIT WHERE IT'S DUE AND
I KNOW THAT HE'S SUCH A
TREMENDOUS JOB HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO WANT TO CONTINUE
TO HONOR HIS WORK AND HIS IS
YET. TO GIVE THEM SOME TIME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK HE'S DONE
HEARING CALIPHS YEAH BUT BASED
ON OUR STATION I KNOW THAT WE
CAME TO A CONCLUSION AND YOU
KNOW MISTER I. CAN FEEL BOTH
AGREED THAT ANY HE SHOULD BE
FOCUS ON CONSUMER. AND WE ALSO
AGREED THAT. WE WANTED HIM SURE
THE OUR TUMORS GET A BETTER
DEAL AND ALLOW WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE IT DID CIRCUMVENT
PROP ONE OH THREE. AND THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY KEEP THE POWER
WITHIN THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND SO I WANT TO
MAKE A PAYMENT OUT PROVISION
THAT SAYS IT'S NOT SUBJECT TO
JUDICIAL REPEAL. WAS WITH
CERTAIN THAT THE INDUSTRY MAY
NOT AGREE WITH THIS RULING AND
THEY WOULD START FIGHTING LOOK
TO AND- DINNER. OF THAT
PROVISION. TAKE YOUR AB ONE. TO
ENSURE A THE COMMISSIONER HAVE
THE LAST WORD. THE FINE WORD
AND THAT INDUSTRY COME. IN SUE
HIM SO BASS. A NOT SUBJECT TO
REVIEW MAN. ONCE THE COMMISSION
TO MAKE THE LAST STATEMENT HIS
LAST RULING. IT IS DONE. THAT
INDUSTRY DOESN'T GET TO TAKE
THEM BACK TO COURT AND TRY TO
CHANGE HIS FOR HIS FILING SO
IT'S REALLY MADE. BUT THAT
INTENT TO SATISFIED SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HARVEY
ROSENFIELD- HAD AND I
APPRECIATE OUR DISCUSSIONS.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT CONCERNED
HERE BUT I WANTED TO ASSURE
EVERYONE THAT IT WAS DONE. WITH
THAT THE BEST INTENTIONS TO
GIVE THE COMMISSIONER THAT
ABSOLUTE- BUT THE ALREADY. AND
NUMBER TWO WE ALSO ADDED
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
ABOUT THE- PROP ONE ALL THREE
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT
DIDN'T CIRCUMVENT THE PROCESS
AND I KNOW I. CONCERNED STILL
AND ONE OF THE THINGS I WOULD
DO. IS THAT I. GOING THANK. BOB
THERE THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL.
TO RETELL TO THE COME BECAUSE
THIS SHOW BE. A BILL THAT.
EVERYONE A SHOULD BE
COLLABORATIVE IT SHOULD PUT THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER IN THE
CENTER. AND DOT LAST YEAH I
WOULD SAY I KNOW I MAY NOT SEE
MICHAEL THEY'RE RELATED BUT I
THINK WE HAVE THREE CRISIS IS
ON OUR HANDS NUMBER ONE WE DO
HAVE COVER NINETEEN. NUMBER TWO
WE DO HAVE THE UNEMPLOYMENT
WHICH IS ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
ISSUES. BUT WE'RE FORGETTING
THE THREE PRONG WHICH IS
WORKING HEADING INTO FIRE
SEASON. AND WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH THIS SENSE YOU KNOW THE
DEVASTATION SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
SO THIS DOES BECOME ORIGIN IN
THE SENSE THAT. WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE SOMETHING IS IN THE WORKS
TO HELP THOSE FOLKS THAT ARE
UNABLE TO GET INSURANCE IN THE
WE AREA. FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
INSURE THEM THIS IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THE CONSUMERS HAVE
OPTIONS THEY'RE NOT DROPPED
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO TO THE
FAIR PLAN WHICH MAKES IT SO
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE. AND
THEREFORE I THINK THAT IT'S
EMPTY NOW WE DE. CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE IN COMMITTEE. AND
I HOPE THAT IS NOT THE FOR.
VERSION THAT YOU DO YOU CHAU TO
HAMMER ALSO HARVEY REAL.
BECAUSE HE IS REALLY AN IMPORT.
TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA HE BRINGS-
YOU KNOW RAIL REALLY VALID
POINTS AND HE'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE HE- IS THAT ONE PERSON
THAT IS ALL OF OUR CONSCIENCE
AND I DO APPRECIATE HIM.
COLLEEN AND GIVING US THAT
PERSPECTIVE AND SO AT THIS
POINT I'M GONNA HAVE PULSE WE
ARE HOW. THE BELIEVE WE HAVE. A
IS ON AT THE POINT SO I'M GONNA
HAVE RESET THANK BACK TED. TO
ME BUT THE- IS GOING TO OFFER.
TELL SUCH TIME AYE CAUCUSES ARE.
BOB MR DAILY BOB DO YOU MIND.
HELLO CAN YOU CLOSE AND A FEW
SECONDS BECAUSE OUR CALL FOR A.
I APPRECIATE ALL THE COR ACTS
COURSE. BY PRE MISTER
PORTANTINO COMMON ABOUT TO THE
PROSPECT FOR FUTURE MEMON IDEA
YOU WE WILL RE OUT TO THE
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE AND TRY
TO WORK OUT. OF ANY REMAINING
DETAILS AND FIND THE BEST
POSSIBLE SWEET SPOT SO THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND I WILL APPRECIATE
YOUR VOTE. BUT YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO. RECESS
AT THAT IT COULD BE QUICK BUT
THE REALITY IS THAT ARE
CAUCUSES ARE WAITING SO I NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A SET
TIME FOR. FOR ANYBODY HEARING
BE THE HEARING THEY KNOW WHEN
TO TUNE IN WE WILL RECESS UNTIL
I BELIEVE THEY SAID ONE THIRTY
IS APPROPRIATE AND WE WILL NOT
CONVENE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE THOSE OF YOU
LISTENING. AND I MEAN OUTSIDE
THE CHAMBERS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND WE WILL BE BACK AT ONE
THIRTY THANK YOU.
GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR JOINING US ONCE AGAIN WE
ARE RE CONVENING. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE- THIS
TUESDAY AUGUST FOURTH- JUST TO
CLARIFY WE WILL CONCLUDE WITH A
B. TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN. AND
WE HAVE ONE MORE PRESENTATION
AP THIRTY TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY
WOOD. AND TWO ITEMS ON CONSENT
AP AT TWENTY FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY. AT.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY A
FAMILY MEMBER THE MALL. IF MR
COOLEY PRESENT I'M SORRY MR
DAILY PRESENT. OKAY YES FOUR
BOWLS. OKAY. I WILL TAKE A
MINUTE HANS TO ALLOW OTHER
MEMBERS WHO ARE ON THEIR WAY TO
JOIN US. YES.
YEAH IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME WE DO HAVE TWO
ITEMS ON CONSENT SO WE WILL
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE CONSENT
ITEM EIGHTY TWENTY FORTY NINE
BY A SEMI COOLLY AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER R. LEE MALONE.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS FOR
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX AND
YOU PASS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR A. B. TWENTY FORTY
NINE. YEAH HI RUBIO BY JONES.
JONES ALL THE LITTLE HI. HELLO
ALL STATE. HI ALL ORDERS. PAUL
GLOBAL WARMING HI ALL THE ALL
THE ALL GLAZER. SENATOR GLAZER
HI. HELLO HI SO I WILL IT THE
INITIAL HI MITCHELL ALL.
MORLOCK AND HERE'S- FOUR TWENTY
NINE I FORTINO HI RALPH. WELL
HI. THE BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES.
MORE LIKE I THOUGHT I. THANK
YOU I SEE THAT THAT- SOME OF
THE MEMBERS HAVE NOW JOINED US
AND JUST POINT OF ORDER I WILL
COME BACK TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TO CONCLUDE WITH- MR
DAILY SPELL **** THE ORDER.
DESOTO TO PLACE ON CALL THANK
YOU WELCOME BACK TO CONSENT.
THANK YOU- RIGHT NOW I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE AT TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN- WE APOLOGIZE TO
EVERYONE THAT WE HAD TO TAKE. A
SHORT BREAK AS WE HAD OTHER
COMMITMENTS TO ATTEND TO SO
AGAIN ONCE IT OUR APOLOGIES FOR
RUSHING THROUGH I KNOW THAT. MR
DAILY IT WAS ABOUT TO GIVE HIS
CLOSING- MISTER WAS I'LL HAVE
HAS ASKED TO SPEAK FOR A FEW
SECONDS. SO GRANTED MR WESSEL.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS YOU KNOW I
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I FEEL
LIKE A NOBLE TAKES ME AWAY FROM
THE CONVERSATION OF BEING ABLE
TO INFLUENCE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE MAKE THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE IT REQUIRES OUR
TIME AND ATTENTION TO REALLY
GET IT RIGHT NOW I'D LIKE TO BE
PART OF THAT. PROCESS SO I'M
GONNA GO UP ON THE BILL. WITH
THE- WITH THE- CONDITION. THAT
WE WORK ON THIS BILL AND WE
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS IN
IT AND- I RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
CHANGE MY VOTE SHOULD COME TO
THE FORCE WOULD NOT COME TO. AN
AGREEMENT BUT I HOPE THAT WE
CAN BRING OUR COMMISSIONER TO
THE TABLE. I HOPE THAT- WE
COULD WORK TOGETHER COME TO A
BETTER PLACE- WHERE THIS BILL
COULD REALLY. WORK BETTER FOR
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TO GO
UP ON THE BILL I APPRECIATE.
YOU GIVING THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPLAIN. A MINUTE CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
AS WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR AS
FAR WANT TO GIVE. I'M SENATOR
MITCHELL HAS JUST JOINED US SO
I WILL ALSO GIVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SAY A FEW WORDS GO AHEAD
SENATOR MITCHELL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM CHAIRWOMAN.
SIMILARLY TO THE COMMENTS MADE
BY MY COLLEAGUE IN SAN DIEGO
HOWEVER I'M GOING TO STAY OFF
THE BILL TODAY. THIS IS A VERY
VERY NEEDY PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE.
I THINK FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THE
PRNCIPAL TENET OF WHAT. I
UNDERSTOOD THE GOAL TO BE WHICH
WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT
HOMEOWNERS WHO. WERE NO LONGER
BEING PROVIDED COVERAGE I DON'T
KNOW THAT IT'S DIRECTLY
ADDRESSED BY. WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED HERE TODAY. BUT BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THIS KIND OF BILL
IS PRECISELY WHY WE HAVE TWO
CALENDAR YEARS IN THE SESSION.
ON JUST LITTLE CONCERNED I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE
TIME. TO GET THROUGH. ALL OF
THE ISSUES ARE AND I STAND
REMAIN CONCERNED. BY A NUMBER
OF ISSUES RAISED BY CONSUMERS.
AROUND CONSUMER PROTECTION.
ISSUES AROUND THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS. YOU KNOW VOTER
APPROVED POWERS. I JUST THINK I
AM NOT COMFORTABLE TODAY ON THE
VOTING ON THE BILL. GIVEN ITS
CURRENT STATE AND GIVEN THE
REALITY OF HOW MUCH TIME WE'VE
HAD TO REVIEW IT. AND MUCH HOW
MUCH TIME WE HAVE LEFT ON THE
CLOCK FOR THE SESSION. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS. I WILL NOT BE
VOTING ON THE BILL TODAY. THE
YOU SENATOR MITCH AND I'LL
LEAVE THE LAST WORDS TO VICE.
SENATOR JOHN THANK MA'AM
CHARGES FOR BRIEFLY I'M TO I
JUST THINK FOR THE- DEBATE THE
MORNING AND THIS AFTERNOON
REGARDING THIS BILL I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF. GOOD ISSUES
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP. AS MY
COLLEAGUES- THREE OF US. IN
THIS COMMITTEE REPRESENT. THE
WILD LANDS IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY-
THIS DOES IMPACT OUR
CONSTITUENTS DIRECTLY. AND I
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
POLICY DEBATE THAT WE'VE HAD
HERE TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO THE CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS. I ALSO WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE CHAIR
OF APPROPRIATIONS FOR HIS- VERY
WISE COMMENTS EARLIER. AND AS A
MEMBER OF APPROPRIATIONS- AGREE
WITH HIM AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING A CONTINUING THIS DEBATE
APPROPRIATIONS. AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE GET A GOOD PRODUCT- OUT
OF THERE ASWELL SO WHAT
THAT'LL MAKE A MOTION FOR THE
BILL AND ASK FOR MY VOTE. THANK
YOU WE HAVE A- ALBUMS. PLEASE
THE ROLL. THE MOST IS TO AS
AMENDED APPROPRIATE AND A
REMINDER REMEMBER MEMBERS SPEAK
INTO A MICROPHONE AS YOU CAST
YOUR VOTE. RUBIO HI. HI JONES I
JONES FIVE LIKE TO LET A HIGH
LEDGE LET HI FATES HI. HI
FORGES. FIVE TELL. KALYANI
GLAZER. SENATOR BECAUSE HI. ALL
WISDOM I WAS HI MITCHELL.
POLACK HI BLOOD HI TINA.
CONTINUE I BYE. TODD. HERE'S
SOME. THE BILL HAS TURNED
BECAUSE THE BILL ACCORDING HOW
TEN FOR I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
AS I SEE IT MR BOARD ANOTHER
SEARCHED ON PRESENT SOUL THANK
YOU MISS DAILY FOR JOINING US
HERE TODAY AND I WILL YOUR WORK
THANK YOU. IMAGE NOW WE WILL
SEE FOR US MEMBER WERE ON
EIGHTY THREE FIVE UP TO HIM AS
WELL I KNOW HE HAS A COMMITTEE
TO CHAIR AT TWO O'CLOCK
HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET HIM OUT ON
TIME SO I THINK IT'S ON THE
MEMBER AND WHEN YOU'RE- READY
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. HERE
TO PRESENT A B. THIRTY TWELVE.
IN OCTOBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
TUBBS FIRE CHANGE MY HOMETOWN
OF SANTA ROSA FOREVER. THE FIRE
DESTROYED FIVE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
STRUCTURES TOOK THE LIVES OF
TWENTY TWO PEOPLE NEARLY ALL OF
THEM WERE FROM COMMUNITIES I
REPRESENT. SINCE IN MY STAFF
AND I HAVE SPENT COUNTLESS
HOURS WORKING WITH CONSTITUENTS
AND THEIR INSURANCE COMPANIES.
EVEN OUR BEST TO HELP
CONSTITUENTS GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET. TWO AND A HALF LATER TWO
AND A HALF YEARS LATER. YOU CAN
SEE THE REBUILDING PROCESS WELL
UNDERWAY IN CINEMA COUNTY. I
LEARNED A LOT OF LESSONS SINCE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN INCLUDING HOW
ILL PREPARED WE WERE FOR THIS
NEW NORMAL. SO MANY PLANS FOR
FIRE TORNADOS OR WILDFIRES THAT
BURNED SO FAST AND SO HOT THEY
JUMPED EIGHT LANES OF FREEWAY.
ENTERING CARS INTO MOLTEN METAL.
NOT EVEN INSURANCE COMPANIES
PLAN FOR THAT KIND OF
DEVASTATION. WE'VE BEEN
WRESTLING WITH THE AFTERMATH
EVERSENSE. AB THIRTY TWELVE IS
NOT A SILVER BULLET BUT I THINK
IT'S A SERIES OF BALANCE STEPS
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION. THE
BILL THOSE FIVE THINGS NUMBER
ONE IT BUILDS ON THE HOME
INSURANCE FINDER THAT MY BILL
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY FIVE
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TO HELP CONNECT HOMEOWNERS WITH
COMPANIES THAT MAY NOT HAVE BIG
ADVERTISING BUDGETS BUT MAY BE
WILLING TO OFFER HOMEOWNER'S
INSURANCE. FOR OTHERS ARE NOT.
NUMBER TWO IT PROHIBITS
INSURERS FROM DEDUCTING THE
LAND VALUE OF THE PROPERTY IF
THE HOMEOWNER CHOOSES TO
REBUILD. OR BUY A HOME NEW HOME
SOMEWHERE ELSE. IT SAYS THAT IF
A HOME IS LOST DURING A
DECLARED DISASTER INSURERS MUST
OFFER 30% OF THE DWELLING
COVERAGE LIMITS UP TO TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WITH NO ITEM IS ATION
LIMIT REQUIRED. REMEMBER IN
THESE CASES THE MAJORITIES
THESE WERE COMPLETE LOSSES.
THAT EXCEEDED. THE VALUE IN
MANY CASES UP 260% OF PEOPLE'S.
FULL INSURANCE- PULLED HIM OUT
OF INSURANCE. THE FOUR THIS
REQUIRES INSURERS TO CONTINUE
PLAYING PAYING ADDITIONAL
LIVING EXPENSES IF THE HOME IS
REBUILT. BUT NOT YET
INHABITABLE DUE TO INSUFFICIENT
INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS A WATER
SYSTEM THAT MAY THAT IS STILL
DOWN THE ELECTRIC GRID THAT HAS
NOT BEEN REPLACED. AND FINALLY
A. B. THIRTY TWELVE REQUIRES
THE FAIR PLAN TO CREATE A
CLEARING HOUSE TO HELP INSURERS
GIVE HOMEOWNERS OFTEN VERY
EXPENSIVE FAIR PLAN.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL CONTAINS
SOME LANGUAGE THAT UPDATES
PROVISIONS RELATED TO
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ANYONE
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF THE HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS I AM
INSTITUTING A TIME LIMIT FOR
TESTIMONY TODAY FOR FOUR
MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE- AND
AGAIN IF YOU HAVE MORE THAN
ONE. WITNESS I CAUTION. YOU TO
MONITOR YOUR TIME SYLLABLE
WITNESSES SPEAK. AND WE WILL
SEE YOU MAY PUT. CHAIR MEMBERS
NOR WILL I BE I OF THE IN.
INSURANCE AGENTS AND
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE INSURANCE GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION COUPLE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL THE HOME FINDER
AND THE CLEARING HOUSE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL THAT.
THAT INDEPENDENT AGENTS SUPPORT
THE CLEARING HOUSE PROVISIONS
WILL ALLOW INSURERS THAT MIGHT
HAVE AVAILABLE RISK TO TAKE-
HOMEOWNERS RISKS OUT OF THE
FAIR PLAN AND HELP TO POPULATE
THAT. CAN DO IT THROUGH YOUR
LOCAL INSURANCE AGENT OR BROKER
WE THINK THAT. HOLDS THE
POTENTIAL HARM TO HELP T.
POPULATE THE FAIR PLAN TO GIVE
CONSUMERS A LOWER. CAR
INSURANCE HAVE THESE TYPE OF
CLEARING IN OTHER STATES AND
THEY DO WORK- WITH REGARDTO
THE- CALIFORNIA TERMS GUARANTY
ASSOCIATION THERE ARE
PROVISIONS IN. THIS BILL THAT.
DO NUMBER CLEAN UP THINGS THAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE TEN FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO TO BE WITH REGARD TO
THE GUARANTEE OF SOCIALIZATION.
SOCIALIZATION IS HANDLED ALL
THE INSOLVENCY OF OVER THIRTY
INSURERS IN THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS OR SO AND DURING THAT
PROCESS WHICH INVOLVES BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. SIR HAVE COME TO
LIGHT SOME IN THE STATE OF THE
CLEANING. AND DOWN THE NO. TO
ANY OF THE THEY BEEN ARKANSAS
PREVIOUSLY WITH I URGE I ON THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT IN THE GALLERY.
RIGHT NOW WE WILL CALL TWO
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OR THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THAT WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIRTY
EIGHT B. THIRTY TWELVE. I SEE
NINE. WE WILL NOW MOVE AT TWO
WITNESSES TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT B.
THIRTY TWELVE WE WILL BEGIN.
SHARE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW AN
OPERATOR WILL GIVE MY NUMBER.
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS. ONE BEEN THERE NOW. AND
WE HAVE A LOT FOUR THE QUEUE.
LOCAL LINE ONE PLEASE GO OUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON HE WROTE WHERE.
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. YOUR
AVAILABLE ACCOUNT LINE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARKET
SEGMENT WITH A MERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALLY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION
I'LL BE HAPPY TO SEE I HUNDRED
ASSOCIATION OF SECOND TRY
COMPANY WERE ON THE BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND THAT GLOBAL.
FORTY FIVE. WE'VE GOT. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M NOT INSURED
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING ON THE
EDGE OF THE NEVADA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT
TODAY AND THANK YOU DOCTOR WITH.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT LEVEL
ACCOUNT LINE FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE OUR
MONTHLY COUNTER REPRESENTING
THE PAY PLAN WE DO NOT HAVE PUT
IT ON THE OTHER PROVISIONS OF
AB THIRTY TWELVE BUT WE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CLEARINGHOUSE LANGUAGE WE DO
APPEAL CAN HELP LESSEN THE
CONCENTRATION ALLOW SOME FOLKS
TO GO BACK TO THE PRINTER.
DRIVER THIS TIME WE JUST TAKING
THE POSITION. YOU ANYBODY ELSE.
N. AS VERY. TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS THE ONE BUTTON
ZERO NOW. AGAIN FOR SUPPORT
ZERO NOW. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU AT THE MOMENT.
THANK YOU JUST TO BE SURE CAN
YOU JUST CHECK ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE THANK YOU. AND AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. WE DID NOT SHOW
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS HERE
FOR THE OPPOSITION- WE'LL START
WITH THE CALORIE ANYBODY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
YOU MAY DO SO NOW. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CERTAIN TAILORED TO
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION.
OF I DO WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE WORK ON THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS THEY SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPROVED THE BILL.
UNFORTUNATELY WE REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
COST IMPACTS PARTICULARLY WITH
THE EXPANSION OF THE DIGITAL
LIVING EXPENSES. BUT WE DO
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE MANY OTHER
SUPPORTABLE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL AND APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYBODY IN
GALLERY. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THE SCENE NINE WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY ON A. B. THIRTY TWELVE.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I FEEL
COLD PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
THERE IS NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THE MOMENT. THANK YOU I SEE YOU
CHECKED TWICE SO WE WILL MOVE
ON. AT THIS POINT. I WANTED TO
BRING IT DOWN TO OUR MEMBERS
ANY MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL YOU MAY DO SO AT THIS
TIME. OKAY I DON'T SEE ANYONE
RAISING THEIR MICROPHONES WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED. RUBIO HI ALL JONES HI
JONES FIVE ELEVEN HI ANGELA ON.
HI ALL FORGES. CALCIUM HI. ON
CLOSER. THAT'S GLAZER HI. ALL
RIGHT SO I. HI LITTLE HIGH
MICHELLE FOR A LOT. CONSTANTINA
CONSTANTINA BROUGHT OUR WELL
DONE OKAY. THE BILL HAS A LOT
OF THE- I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN AT AND MA'AM THANK YOU SO
FOR ME MA'AM WHAT. MEMBERS
THANK YOU AT THIS WE WILL GO
BACK. CONSENT CAN TO UP. WE
HAVE EIGHTY TWENTY FORTY NINE
KOHLI AND AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SIX A FAMILY MEMBER LEVEL AND
WE WILL TAKE FULL ROLL CALL
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RUBIO HI RUBIO HI JONES. JONES
I THAT'S A LITTLE. ON JULY BYE
PHASE I BABES HI PURCHASED.
TODD HI TODD HI DALE G. O.
CALGENE FIVE GLAZER. SENATOR
GLAZER HI GLAZER ALL. HI WAY SO
LITTLE HI RACHEL HI HELLO HI
BYE DO YOU KNOW HI I TWELFTH.
WELL THOUGHT CONSULT CALENDAR
HAS OUT. THANK YOU WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE FOR AT MA'AM FOR
TEN. I WILL TAKE A SHORT PAUSE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE TEN
MINUTES TO COME TO THE FLOOR.
YEAH. REPORTER FOR THE
PRIVILEGE. YEAH.
WE WILL RESUME
INSURANCE COMMITTEE I'VE BEEN
ADVICE- THAT MR BORJAS IS
PRESENTING A BILL IN ORDER TO
DO NOT HOLD EVERYONE UP HERE I
WILL OPEN IT UP. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AB.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN FOR
THOSE APPS AND MEMBERS THAT
HAVE JOINED US. IS TEN ZERO.
FOUR JUST MITCHELL. ROB RALPH
HI BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES THAT I
HAVE ELEVEN VOTES WILL PUT IT
ON A CALL FOR ACTION MEMBERS
LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR AP THIRTY
TWELFTH PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CURRENT BOAT IS ELEVEN ZERO
BORTLES. POLACK. THE REMAINS
ELEVEN VOTES WITH ELEVEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE DOOR OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
PROCEED TO CONSENT CALENDAR AP.
204-980-2750 SIX. PORCHES. BILL
US FOR VOTES CAN WE WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ONCE AGAIN WE WILL TAKE.
A SHORT RECESS. TO FIFTEEN TO
ALLOW MR BURGESS TO COMPLETE
HIS HIS PRESENTATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ONCE AGAIN WILL
RESUME TWO TO FIFTEEN.
HELLO
EVERYONE WELCOME BACK WE WILL
NOW RETURN TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE TO ALLOW
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
MEMBERS TO VOTE. WE WILL START
WITH EIGHTY TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SEVEN DAILY SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GLOBAL ACCOUNT
IS ELEVEN ZERO JUST HI BORDERS
HI MITCHELL. BILL HAS TWELVE
FOOT THE BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE ONTO EIGHTY
THIRTY TWELVE BY A MEMBER WHAT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
KLAEBO IS ELEVEN ZERO. FOUR
JUST HI. FORTY FIVE MORLOCK.
BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES THE BILLS
OUT. THANK YOU WE WILL NOW
PROCEED TO CONSENT CALENDAR ABC
TWENTY FORTY NINE BY MR COOLEY
AT TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
ACCOUNT IS CLOSER FORTIS.
BORDERS HI PHYLLIS THIRTEEN
VOTES BILLS OUT. THANK YOU
FIRST OF ALL WE WANT THANK ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THIS PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO US. AND
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND YOUR PATIENCE AS WE BROKE.
TO ACCOMMODATE MEMBERS THANK
YOU ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE IS NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.